avec Bollène Fred bonjour Hélène bonjour
Pauline à la une de la presse le
discours sur l'état de l'Union de la
présidente de la Commission européenne
Ursule à funderlione devant les euros
députés ce sera à Strasbourg aujourd'hui
à partir de 9h à suivre en direct sur
notre antenne mais d'abord dans la
presse face à la crise énergétique lieu
choisira-t-elle l'unité ou le repli
national à l'image de ce qui s'est passé
durant la pandémie la croix annonce en
tout cas que les mesures pour faire face
à cette crise seront au cœur du discours
d'orsulafone d'après le journal les 27
sont d'accord pour le moment pour
réduire leur consommation d'énergie mais
pas sur l'étendue de l'effort à fournir
il n'est pas certain que les pays qui
disposent de stock à des niveaux très
bas comme l'Irlande la Finlande la Grèce
ou la Slovénie vont pouvoir compter sur
le soutien des autres pays de l'UE bref
l'exercice s'annonce compliqué pour la
patronne de l'UE selon Slate qui
présente son discours de mi-mandat comme
sans doute le plus important de rece
appelle donc les Européens à l'unité à
faire front commun face à la Russie la
bataille énergétique prévient le journal
est sans doute la bataille que l'Europe
démocratique ne peut pas se permettre de
perdre disco à suivre donc je le redis
en direct sur notre antenne elle va
parler à 440 millions de personnes
Ursula faune derrière l'Union européenne
Hélène qui demande la ré immédiaire d'en
parler dans le journal des hostilités
après la dernière escalade des violences
entre l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan alors
que les deux pays vous l'avez dit se
rejettent la responsabilité des
violences qui ont éclatées dans la nuit
de lundi à mardi le quotidien turc
délice à Bar rappelle kankara c'est
rangé aux côtés de l'Azerbaïdjan et
affirme que les tensions entre les deux
anciens pays de l'Union soviétique
remonte à 1991 lorsque l'armée
arménienne a occupé le Carambar un
territoire internationalement reconnu
comme faisant partie de l'Azerbaïdjan le
journal site le président turqueur et
cheptel qui accuse la communauté
internationale d'être resté silencieuse
face à l'occupation des territoires
azerbaïdjanais par l'Arménie du moins
jusqu'à l'automne 2020 lorsque
l'Azerbaïdjan a repris ses terres avec
l'aide de la Turquie le franc Fortin
algobains
comme la puissance protectrice de
l'Arménie avant d'adopter une attitude
beaucoup plus ambiguë que c'est traduite
notamment par la vente d'armes à Lazare
bahdjan aujourd'hui cette ancienne
puissance protectrice bloque l’arménie
qui demande frénétiquement de l'aide du
soutien interpelle le journal encore
faut-il pouvoir agir le quotidien
français l'humanité souligne que le se
retrouve aujourd'hui fortement
dépendante de Bakou pour ses
approvisionnements énergétiques une
dépendance accrue depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine et évidemment la
fermeture du robinet russe toujours
Hélène à la rubrique géopolitique la
visite à partir d'aujourd'hui de sinjin
Pino Kazakhstan puis en Ouzbékistan
c'est le premier voyage à l'étranger
depuis pour le président chinois depuis
le début de la pandémie de covid il y a
3 ans janvier 2020 plus précisément
selon le journal officiel de Global time
cette double visite démontre que la
Chine attache une grande importance à la
fois la vie centrale et à l'OCS
l'Organisation de Coopération Shanghai
qui se veut comme une alternative
asiatique au G7 et dans le sommet va se
tenir à sa marquant de la mythique ville
des routes de la soie en Ouzbékistan
lors de sommet le président chinois
rencontrera son homologue russe
également pour la première fois depuis
le début de la guerre en Ukraine d'après
le quotidien américain le Wall set
journal Vladimir Poutine pourrait à
cette occasion demander à chigin ping
une aide économique supplémentaire pour
l'aider évidemment à contrer les
sanctions occidentales la Chine enfant
Hélène ou les cinéphiles ont rendu
hommage sur les réseaux sociaux aussi
vaste franco-suisse Jean-Luc Godard
disparu à 91 ans pour Libération elle
était tout simplement le plus grand des
cinéastes un cinéaste total au millevie
et à l'oeuvre aussi prolifique que
protéiforme Libé décidément Forever
Godard hommage également ce matin en
France de l'humanité la Suisse n'est pas
que le pays des coucou et du chocolat au
lait chez Godard écrit l'Huma rien à
jeter il faut tout prendre chez un
artiste de cette trempe qui a su filmer
avec une telle intensité les affres de
l'amour et les vertiges politiques de la
société de son temps et mes films tu les
aimes je les clin d'oeil ce matin à la
Une du journal suisse Le Temps clin
d'oeil évidemment à l'une de ses œuvres
les plus connues le film Le Mépris avec
cette très belle photo elle est signée
Richard Dumas elle était prise en 1998
Jean-Luc Godard on le voit regarde Paris
la même ou fut tournée le mythique à
bout de souffle le film emblématique de
la Nouvelle Vague merci beaucoup Hélène
c'était la revue de presse